Every existence multiplied by
possibility
life a precious gift persevering in the
face of every obstacle
till finally
the Age of Heroes was born why'd you
why'd you choose a condemned building
what no this is not a condemned building
no listen this is an old STAR Labs
research facility that nobody uses and
what's even better no one knows it
exists good for you no good for us I
figure we could all use this to gather if
anything ever happens again. it's a great
idea Barry. Thanks Superman!
oh it's like that? Don't worry, I was the new kid
last year all right listen I haven't
even showed you guys the best part yet
you ready
should live with that bro
yeah not bad! I love it
it's perfect
sounds like we need to call pest control
What is that?
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new crisis on Infinite earths
video for the end credit scenes
and all the stuff that they set up also
talk about what's going on with future
crossovers the Superman stuff would
happen to the Smallville characters in
all the Green Lantern's stuff that
they're setting up for the Green Lantern
HBO show so if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get everything
we're doing that flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the end credits scenes
obviously spoiler warning for all the
stuff that happened during crisis on
Infinite Earths I think most of you have
seen it or seen the most important parts
by now so hopefully you're at least a
little caught up but the big stuff here
is there obviously canonizing Green
Lantern's in the Green Lantern Corps to
the arrowverse using footage from the
Green Lantern movie so they're basically
saying that Ryan Reynolds movie is now
canon - the arrow verse but it's also
meant to be a teaser for the Green
Lantern HBO show that they're working on
that's going to premiere in the next couple
of years they even just released a brief
synopsis in the plot description for
that TV show so this will get you really
excited it's going to span multiple decades
covering Sinestro and the lives of two
different Green Lantern's they didn't
say which Green Lantern's but odds are
pretty good that it's Hal Jordan as the
first one and then Jon Stewart is the
second younger one to come along the
synopsis actually kind of makes it sound
like they're doing the plot of the
planned Green Lantern Corps movie that
they had originally wanted to do but
doing it as an 8 to 10 episode HBO show
probably closer to 8 episodes though
because the budgets going to have to be
ridiculous in order for them to do the
special effects I don't know if this
means that they're not going to do the
Green Lantern movie anymore Geoff Johns
was working on a script a couple years
ago when he set up his new production
company but we haven't really heard any
updates about that since then that movie
was pitched as Lethal Weapon in space
with an older version of Hal Jordan
teaching a younger rookie version of Jon
Stewart it sounded really cool so
hopefully at some point they'll get to
do Green Lantern in the movies but I'll
cover more of that in my videos when
they give us some more official details
they'll probably start doing that when
they get ready to drop the Green Lantern
HBO show Oliver narrates all these end
credits scenes and cameos doing a new
origin for this multiverse remember they
rebooted everything DC rebirth style big
easter egg for the DC rebirth of the
comics I take that to mean that he
hasn't been completely wiped but exists
in
kind of limbo cosmic state there are a
billion reasons why cosmic characters
don't walk around showing up all the
time to talk to the characters they also
probably didn't want to ruin his eulogy
at the end in the Hall of Justice the
one thing that they didn't do during
these end credits scenes was have a
scene from the Justice League movie to
let us know which earth number
corresponds to Ezra Miller's Flash
character in the other Justice League
characters like Wonder Woman Henry
Capitol Superman Batman Aquaman I think
they're probably a couple reasons for
that mostly they just want to get too
complicated with things because the
flash movie is going to be doing the
flashpoint plot or a version of
flashpoint so I think they want to let
them do their own thing in the idea that
you get a movie actor cameo inge on the
TV show was already a huge deal so they
probably just wanted to leave it at that
wooda brothers does a studio has also
kind of changed their movie plans for
how everything connects and crosses over
it gets a little bit complicated like
the Robert Pattinson Batman movie in the
Joaquin Phoenix Joker movie best
examples of two movies with really core
DC characters that aren't really
connected to any of the other movies
that are happening Wonder Woman 1984 is
still technically connected to the DC EU
but because it's set during the past
there's no big crossover scenes with the
other characters unless there's some
secret post-credit scene that we don't
know about set in present-day
birds-of-prey is another example of a DC
movie that is connected to all the
Justice League timeline films in present
day because it takes place right after
the events are a little while after the
events of the first Suicide Squad movie
which of course they're completely sort
of wiping from the timeline with James
Gunn's reboot of The Suicide Squad
franchise it does sound a little
confusing when you dig into it so I'll
just address the timeline and continuity
for each different DC movie when they
come along so don't worry too much about
that right now
but speaking of Justice League then they
have their big Justice League Hall of
Justice scene with Barry finally making
it official they introduced this Hall of
Justice looking building a couple years
ago during the dominators crossover but
it was mostly a throwaway joke like well
we should do something with this someday
the whole idea is this is just a spare
warehouse that belongs to STAR Labs so
technically Barry owns that they weren't
using it for anything but the facade is
designed to look exactly like the Hall
of Justice from the Superfriends TV show
so you knew at some point they were
going to be doing their TV Justice
League it was just a
question of when they were going to do it
and when they were going to
quote-unquote unite the seven seven
members of the Justice League that's why
there are seven chairs plus the one for
Oliver is a sort of memorial yes I
totally think that Stephen Amell is
going to come back at some point and cameo
in a future crossover just to kind of
keep one foot in the door so he's not
gone completely even though they killed
him off turned him into the specter in
their ending the arrow TV show if Tom
Welling will come back for a cameo after
Smallville went off the air almost ten
years ago then Stephen Amell is totally
going to come back in cameo every once in a
while you could also say that them
leaving the eighth seat is sort of a
back door for a Green Lantern to
potentially get a seat at the table
eventually because this HBO Green
Lantern TV show but they've been really
cagey about how that's connected or not
connected to the DC TV shows early
prediction because it's going to be on HBO
it'll look very different it'll be way
bigger than all the other DC TV shows is
that it won't be any more connected to
the DC TV shows than say like Titans so
Titans crossed over during crisis on
Infinite Earths they had a scene but
when are you actually going to see those
Titans characters actually appear in a
big way during an episode with the flash
character of Superman or anyone else
probably not anytime soon on top of that
no one in this final end credits scene
says the words Super Friends or Justice
League or league of any kind they just
sit down at the table and have that
funny moment I think that's because one
they're not allowed to use the term
Justice League officially and they're
just trying to be as ambiguous as
possible about it the actual final end
credits scene with Gleek is one
basically a Super Friends TV show Easter
Egg because he was the monkey from that
TV show and they played the theme song
from the Super Friends TV show and -
they're probably actually going to do that
character at some point even though he
as a character would have to be full CG
and he's totally ridiculous if you've
ever watched the Super Friends TV show
it's totally ridiculous it was designed
to be that way on purpose but the tone
of this episode got a little ridiculous
and because it's meant to be the legends
episode of the crossover in legends as a
show is pretty ridiculous I think them
having this funny moment with the Gleek
at the end is totally in keeping with
the tone of the rest of the stuff that
they're doing but there will be a
crossover next year
with basically these seven characters
are seeing here including black
lightning probably coming back
now his earth is technically earth Prime
so although black lightning characters
just live in Freeland on earth Prime
because they're starting their Superman
TV show in the fall and he's basically
their big a-list character the next big
crossover villain might wind up being a
big Superman deep cut villain like
Brainiac it would be the easiest slam
dunk in the world to do Brainiac they're
also kind of implying that this version
of Lex Luthor is going to become the
president of earth prime because they
rebooted the multiverse but now suddenly
he's this hero to the people everyone
loves him he's running the deo it's
just like they're setting him up to
become the US president even though you
don't see Tom Welling or the Smallville
characters come back they did explain
that all the Smallville stuff was put
back the way that they left it so those
characters are fine they didn't really
mess with any of the stuff that they had
established during the Smallville scene
with Tom Welling earlier in the
crossover so all that stuff still stands
after they rebooted the multiverse a lot
of people also wondering where the hell
reversed flashes during this crossover I
was kind of upset by the answer that
Marc Guggenheim game they included him
in some of the promos so they imply that
he would appear in some way and there
was all the future newspaper stuff that
they've been setting up on the flash for
the last six years this will probably
make you upset but Marc Guggenheim
basically said that they didn't want to
do something that another writer set up
so the people that set that stuff up on
the flash with a future newspaper back
in season one don't work on the flash
anymore none of those writers those show
runners are still associated with the DC
TV shows so you have a bunch of other
writers coming in later deciding that
they don't want to deal with the stuff
that the other writers set up which to
me is kind of upsetting I feel like it'd
be pretty easy to have included him in
some way I'll do a couple more crisis on
Infinite Earths videos I'll do some more
Green Lantern stuff but if you have any
special requests or are there any big
Easter eggs you want me to do videos for
just let me know in the comments I'm
working on another new big Spiderman
Morbius video that should post tomorrow
while you wait for everything click here
to re-watch that scene of Ezra Miller's
flash crossing over with Grant Gustin
and all my Easter eggs and click here
for that brand new Spider Man Morbius
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight!